are you okay
[Music]
actors often move us to tears with their
emotional scenes but did you know they
can get
just as tearful as us forget clever
tricks and fake tears
these actors were crying for real in
these scenes
how many times have you bawled your eyes
out at a super sad moment on screen
we hear you and we've been there too but
it's not just
us discover the scenes in movies like
harry potter and tv shows like friends
where the cast got just as choked up as
the audience
get the kleenex ready i teared up a
little bit watching sophie in that scene
filming a scene where your on-screen
twin passes away
sure sounds tough and for oliver phelps
it was very emotional
he asked director david yates and
co-star julie walters how to get into
that mindset
and he revealed he ended up thinking
about loved ones i've lost over the
years
a makeup artist then came over with
eucalyptus spray and blew in his eyes
he admitted i'm crying for real at that
point they did it in just two takes
james phelps wasn't affected at all by
the crying he had to lie there for so
long he actually fell asleep
and woke up on my own on the stage while
everyone went to lunch
will smith's raw performance and the
pursuit of happiness gave us serious
goosebumps
and the emotion in the final scene got
to will himself too
he cried real tears and it's hardly
surprising the actor revealed how
important it was for him to do justice
to the true story it was based on
he connected with chris gardner the real
man he was portraying on screen
so that he could tell his story and
working with his own son jaden when he
was just eight years old
also made it a mega emotional experience
for will
was it as easy as it looked no sir oh no
sir it wasn't riverdale paid tribute to
the late luke perry
following his fatal stroke with its
season four premiere the episode
featured fred andrews's funeral the
character that luke portrayed in the
show given the real life events
it's not surprising that the cast were
crying real tears of grief and loss
as they mourned their former co-star it
was an immensely moving moment for all
of us watching at home as well
and a beautiful way to pay tribute we're
honoring him the best we could
it was the best way yeah the ending of
captain phillips wasn't in the original
script it was entirely improvised and
that makes tom hanks's raw performance
all the more affecting he let the
emotion of the scene wash over him
the actor revealed that it was
instinctual and he couldn't really
remember
it afterwards as he was just so
physically engrossed in the procedure
that was happening to him he had spoken
to the real person he was portraying
beforehand
and tom had discovered that phillips
couldn't stop crying a navy seal had
told him
not to fight it and let it flow out of
his system and that's exactly what tom
did
everything's gonna be okay denzel
washington shows so much
in such a small physical moment when he
lets a tear fall down his cheek
as he's flogged in glory his back
already bears the scars of his
punishment as a runaway slave it's an
incredibly moving moment and highlights
the power of the actor
the cast of glee paid tribute to cory
monteith after his tragic passing with a
beautifully touching episode titled the
quarterback
the actors tears were of course real as
the cast let their raw emotion
show while acting their characters
mourning the passing of finn
leah michelle was in a real relationship
with corey at the time of his
passing and her genuine tears as she
sang adele's make you feel my love
moved us all to tears too come on
let's hang it right over there
when eleven reads an emotional letter
left for her by police chief hopper in
the final episode her tears are
seriously convincing
and that's because millie bobby brown
was genuinely crying
the actor has discussed how she got
herself into the zone to deliver the
emotional scenes
in stranger things third season she
listened to the recording from her
co-star david harbour
and got the camera on her straight away
to capture her raw reaction which she
describes as pure devastation
and sadness and when life hurts you
because it will
remember the hurt finishing up a
franchise of films is going to be
emotional
and that's exactly how daisy ridley felt
when her role as rey in the star wars
series
came to a full stop she was so upset
about the end of the line that she
didn't need to pretend to cry in her
emotional scenes
those tears flowed naturally in an
interview she revealed
in the shot i'm just crying in the shot
it was it was
incredibly dramatic she literally
couldn't remember what she said
afterwards
she just hugged the cast and crew and
left in a car staring out of the window
saying goodbye to their sitcom of 10
years was a very emotional moment for
the cast of friends
so they didn't have to put on the tears
in their final scene
courtney cox starts crying and she sets
off jennifer aniston
and david schwimmer lisa kudrow and matt
leblanc also shed a tear
the only one who didn't matthew perry he
kept it together but admitted he felt
like he was going to cry throughout the
seven
hours of their last day this is harder
than i thought it would be
benedict cumberbatch cared so deeply for
the character he played in the imitation
game that he genuinely cried
in fact on the last day of shooting he
was so moved he couldn't stop the tears
from flowing
the actor revealed that while filming
the final scene he broke down
and couldn't control himself and i
couldn't stop crying
he said he grieved for the beautiful and
brilliant man
during an interview with jimmy kimmel
jennifer lawrence revealed what caused
sophie turner to cry real tears in an
emotional scene
it's the moment when her god-like powers
cause her to accidentally end
jennifer's character's life and it's all
because her vape got taken away
as jen revealed she really was crying
because her
dialect coach right before the take took
her jewel away
sophie joined the joking by saying it's
how to act
take it away and then you give it back
scream is terrifying to watch but was it
terrifying to make
well drew barrymore wanted to cry real
tears so she made an agreement with wes
craven about how to approach the crying
scenes
wes would tell her a secret story and it
brought the tears on
every time wes revealed what their
secret was about it was a story drew had
told him about a boy who had done awful
things to his dog
so the director just had to say one line
to the actor and she'd burst into tears
and be just frantic
drew barrymore has a history of really
crying in her movies
way back when she was little she played
gertie in e.t
and she was able to give a very raw
genuine performance because the cast and
crew
encouraged her to believe the
extraterrestrial was actually real
in a behind-the-scenes featurette her
co-star henry thomas who played elliott
revealed that drew introduced e.t to her
mom and said
he doesn't want to talk to you right now
but he's just a little shy
her co-star robert mcnaughton said it
must have been very upsetting for her
when she had to say goodbye to e.t
jessica elba's crying scene in fantastic
four rise of the silver surfer
is fascinating for a different reason
she revealed that making the movie
actually made her want to stop acting
and that's all down to director tim
storey's response to her genuine crying
she revealed that the director said her
crying looked too real
and too painful well duh that's how it's
supposed to be but then
get this he added can you be prettier
when you cry cry
pretty jessica just wow he wanted her to
make her face
flat so they could then cgi the tears in
as jessica quite
rightly pointed out then there's no
connection to a human being
you need to find a way to get the board
when steve carell's character left the
office in season seven
fans were moved to tears but they also
had a lingering question
which was what did pam say to michael at
the airport well the actor behind pam
jenna fisher revealed all years later in
an instagram live video
she explained that it was actually her
talking to steve rather than pam talking
to michael she told him all the ways she
was going to miss him so they were
real tears and a real goodbye she
described it as a really
emotional scene he's gonna feel so good
getting this thing off my chest which of
these scenes made you cry the most when
you watched it we hope we didn't make
you bawl your eyes out all over again
be sure to let us know in the comments
which actor's genuine tears moved you
the most and please hit that subscribe
button while you're here thanks for
[Music]
watching